who which ethnicity is worse than
Chinese
damn because I don't even know what
Chinese go that far that's pretty that's
pretty what is this is she at the chef
in ethnicity
[Music]
so this is an am I the [__] type of
uh redditor article however it's pretty
across the board that this person
spoiler is an [__] they're always the
[__] so I figured we'd bring this
story here and make sure that we clear
it up for the people that you know on a
scene every side to the story one woman
uh I guess according to this we'll call
her June went to the Mi to [__] I had
to ask her fellow redditors if she would
be an [__] if she asked her friend
for her 400 baby shower gift back bag
because her friend had a miscarriage
people are debating about that hey dude
you gotta ask you gotta ask okay again
it's like when's the right time to do
this it's kind of like what do you do
with those oh that's okay I bought this
I bought this for your wife
uh but she's dead now so I'll take it
back oh god dude take backs that's
[__] up that's [__] crazy but was
it one of those fancy strollers uh those
are pretty famous what could that be she
said she sounded awful uh or or
acknowledged that it sounded awful and
it was a terrible thing to do by
possibly asking for the gift bag but she
said her husband spent a decent bit of
cash on that item that would go to waste
and likely never be used is it like a
time sensitive use who which ethnicity
is worse than Chinese
damn because I don't even know what
Chinese would go that far that's pretty
that's pretty [__] up what is this is
she at the chef in ethnicity
what a nice way to ask that question
yeah
I think it's state Anonymous see I knew
it you could guess from the vernacular
is it real name June no okay it's like
Korean
[Laughter]
it's one thing if she's able to get a
few years of use out of the item that's
money well spent but if it's going to
sit in a box in her attic for years
that's where we're getting stuck it's a
gift bro you can do whatever you want
with it exactly as soon as you give it
you forget about it it's a [__] gift
what the [__] dude they had a
miscarriage you just keep your mouth
shut for a while don't you how about you
give them more [__] yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah dude does it change it if she
through some form of bad habit caused
the miscarriage
oh then you gotta ask for that you gotta
ask for that back you gotta be like
doing that thing threw herself down and
fly to stairs that's also like in the
Friendship would that would that be uh
no she wouldn't stop drinking uh surge
Cola what if she had the baby and then
she gave the baby away
how about that it was a miscarriage oh
no like if the baby made it it's a real
Carriage
that's a transfer the baby awake us for
a back right my [__] bought this
for you yeah yeah
for that dude come on yeah what if it
wasn't Real miscarriage and they just
said it was miscarriage but it was an
abortion what to get a gift card
that never happens that's a late turn
nobody does is that a scam on purpose is
that a thing that people do and then
they just recently yeah
is it no stop asking to be like that I'm
asking you legitimately no have you
heard of people that have done that no
yes is the answer of course it's been
done right but that's [__] crazy
that's magic because you're I I mean I
can't imagine but you'd have to go so
much going through your body just to get
well for this situation get a gift card
um
or what if this person is asking it back
really does think that's what they did
they did uh they pulled a fast one or
maybe they're just going through
financial terms you're like well the way
they're asking because they're asking
they're second guessing their own
question
dude if you have to ask Reddit dude
don't even [__] ask it
do it bro yeah you figure that you're
asking Reddit either because you really
don't know yeah so God help you or
you're trying to validate something that
you like kind of do know already the
answer or she asked everybody that's her
friend and they all looked at you like
what the [__] is wrong with you yeah
they're like dude that's terrible yeah
then she was like well just to double
check yeah it's like you guys are all
wrong you're all wrong is there anything
that any of you guys have given away
that you wish you could have it back no
because I have two items that are always
at the top of my list what virginity
I didn't have a teddy bear I had a
stuffed raccoon yeah and then my 16 year
old girlfriend I gave that to her and
then when we broke up like I'm I'm a
Believer like whatever I gave us
whatever I gave but I'm like but that
was my [__] childhood raccoon though
and then so if I if I could and it's
just the office she doesn't have it
anymore
I would like I could go back hands of
time I would go in the time machine and
then go in her closet and then grab it
and then go back in the time machine
yeah yeah what was the other one you'd
rather go back in time to steal it than
make sure it didn't happen at all
that one and then my uh high school
wrestling sweater
give it back Jessica
I have the same type of thing like that
too when I gave my um I had a bad
falling out with all my exes and she
kept like the you need to do that safe
keeping stuff where it's like you keep
this I'll keep that yeah and it's like
something equally valuable to both of
you collateral yeah but then like she
didn't give my thing back what was her
it was a it was like a um one of those
old Rolex like Day dates like that my my
dad bought when he was really young and
he like kept constantly selling it to
like get loans and got them through like
most of his life and then he passed it
on to my cousin and then my cousin
passed on to me and then I gave it to
this chick and then she kept it and it's
gone yeah we gotta find this that
definitely is your [__] up though yeah
100 sure like this is a family heirloom
entrusted down to the brothers of the
confirito bloodline let me give it to
this girlfriend
the thing that she gave me was also very
valuable it was like this ring that from
like her grandmother or something but
when we broke up
um I gave it back to her yeah and then
she came running back and was like the
box is empty where the [__] is it and I
was like oh [__] where it should have
been there I never took it out she's
lying and then for a month straight she
would show up to my house and be like
I'm gonna look through your place and
like she would come while I was hanging
out with other like new girls and [__]
to just ruin my [__] yeah whoa after a
month her best friend hit me up and said
wow she's had it the whole time she's
just lying oh she just want to go
through your stuff yeah that's a good
move I would have done that to you
if I was your ex I would have done that
[__] but she was so nuts that like I
couldn't get my [__] back wow so she
just never it's gone so you guys are
still talking or not
she still comes over
no it's like it's it's gone I would love
to get that back that's like who the
[__] is this dude that's great yeah mine
was just a raccoon dude
you take that story back it makes it
feel a little bit better though I know I
would love to freaking End that watch as
Daniel engraved on the inside which is
my dad's name and my real name bro
you're making us wait you're rolling
with Daniel yeah my real name's Daniel
Ryan is what Ryan's my middle name oh
you're a heartbreaker that sucks I wish
I could get that back Daniella May um
when's the last time someone well do
your parents call you Daniel or their
car no just calling Ryan Danny Boy call
you Danny you can if it fits do you'll
like it hey daddy boy damn Daniel Daniel
I think family heirlooms are in that
like Realm though like imagine like
you're [__] old as [__] right and
then like your your wife is like oh this
was my wedding ring it gives you like
you know your daughter or something like
that you know or or the uh your son's
betrothed their fiance or whatever the
[__] you know this is my wedding ring
blah blah and then they break up it's
like give me back the wedding yeah yeah
because that's that to me is like your
family tree whatever that's way stronger
than whatever the [__] going on over
here generational history whatever this
[__] is yeah whatever this [__]
two-year thing that didn't [__] work
out no that's crazy that you just make
dumbass decisions like that when you
think it's yeah but it's the Heat of the
Moment Bros the passion dude you know so
raccoon you know yeah she gave me
something special while bartending
anything is special but like you got
something special so then you were like
I'm gonna return the favor I'm gonna
give you something special but all he
got was [__] nothing you gave her a
raccoon in your sweater I got nothing
that was my [__] childhood raccoon
what'd you give you should give you
anything she I bet she was like oh
thanks
did you lose anything that you want back
you got it all back boy come on
this is really petty and stupid yeah
um or uh and I don't actually want this
bad especially if he's watching I want
my raccoon back but uh I had some just
to be clear
I want it back I'm like you yeah [__]
Jessica get back to me I saw you guys a
boy that one time because during the
pandemic when we had to move out of uh
kinja's Dojo we're just clearing random
[__] out you know when you're like just
you're not mentally this it's like you
know Through the Wire and you're [__]
just cleaning and clearing you got to
move stuff yeah like everything's
stressful and I remember we just I just
had some [__] like random like a
couple dunks just Nike Dunks that I
never wore I just got them when I was
collecting dunks back in like college
just never gone and I was like I'm never
gonna do anything with this right so I
gave one of my uh one of these pairs of
dunks whales but you've held on for like
10 years then yeah for like eight nine
years it wasn't the [__] but it was
like the brown green and yellow one
um I'm blanking on the name and then
dunks have recently been just coming
back in hard again right and everybody's
like yo I sold these nuts for this much
and you think to yourself you're like
man I was trying to be nice but I should
have made money yeah but I if he's
watching this and I'm like I'm so happy
for you he sold the guns you gave them
maybe I hope so I hope he made money
somebody should have won from that
because I lost
but it's better than a raccoon
raccoon do you have a picture of this
raccoon I don't know I'm not sure I
don't think so because it's so old I had
it since I was a kid there's no photo of
you like clutching it disheveled uh
photo albums for sure I have it you
think they make it somewhere
like if you go to like a Disney Store do
they have that raccoon somewhere why a
raccoon of all animals you don't really
hear it I think so I think it's my mom's
friend
gave it to the time traveler you could
time travel holy [__] this is what my
mom was normal when my mom had normal
friends were like they would come over
and sing karaoke instead of tell each
other their [__] Futures and stuff
fortunate parties
my mom's friend gave it to her to give
to me and I've always liked it because I
always thought like oh everyone has a
teddy bear that's so [__] basic my
[__] is a raccoon it's pretty cool that
is kind of cool and it was a brown and
and uh Brown and tan because you just
don't hear raccoon often you know what I
mean yeah that's very fascinating it's
pretty cool I had a little monkey with
little I could I could talk with his
mouth yeah in this video I don't know
let me tell you no no let me share it
you didn't give it away did you no no oh
he's like I still have it it's in my
backpack
[Music]
ha